I don't know if we should just just
chill here and have a drink and enjoy
this view this is insane let's just take
it in this incredible you're in
California I'm in Nevada this is pretty
spectacular pretty great I'm a huge fan
of your work
you know thank you for creating some of
the best movies I've seen but you're
mine you go to places that I dark places
what inspires you to go to that place I
don't know you have to be in a special
place to write like that well I look I
really love I love my characters on
everything I've ever done and I love
putting them through hardship because I
feel like that crucible brings out the
best in human and human kind and so I'm
constantly trying to see how we can how
we can put them through the wringer and
then you have Chris Hemsworth in this
film who's shirtless so it's gonna be a
huge hit right off the top right there
look wearing a shirt but every time we
go camera he just whipped that thing off
I guess I would do if I had his body
that's true and you worked with him
before what is it about him that you
want to work and put it put him in that
dark place as well look he's such a
special performer he is he's such a
gifted actor he's really open he really
can bring his emotions out at the drop
of hat I always look for two things when
we're casting actors can you make me
laugh again you break my heart I keep it
pretty much that simple and chris has a
thing where despite his sort of
celestial looks he's just beautiful
let's just say he's just beautiful
no one's gonna argue that yeah he's so
vulnerable and willing to expose himself
and in the way that you want as a
director and he's a joy to be around so
that also helps now there is a show on
Netflix right now called lawyer where
they talk about a guy who for decades
was watching people that were guests at
his motel it's kind of creepy yes the
whole concept is creepy
yes so for you to go there did you look
at other cases that it happened before
or was this something that you just kind
of created in your mind
it's a little of both I've always had a
fascination with hotels in general oh
and there's been a lot of cases of
Boyer's yeah and also just urban legends
more than real facts I tend to just let
the imagination fly and certainly in the
60s there was at a time of intense
paranoia that you were being watched and
so I just sort of took that and ran with
it and the cast you have these criminals
as well yet a priest you got a singer
and a few few it's a great riddle right
a vacuum cleaner salesman that's right
you got all of them coming together what
was it why did you bring these type of
characters together you know it's not an
intellectual exercise it's just I go I
just tend to write the movie I want to
watch and you just want everyone to be
different you want everyone to come from
different backgrounds in different walks
of life it just makes it more fun and
you can you can have a cast really
bounce off each other when you create
disparity between them
oh boy Cynthia Revo watch out watch out
world when you see what she is capable
of and you will see in this movie she
will be front and center with her talent
so how did you meet her how did you even
pick her to be part of this film so she
plays a character named Arlene sweet and
who was a as a singer in the film I knew
I wanted somebody who could sing live I
knew I would be doing complicated shots
that required live singing I did not
want to lip-sync in this movie ever that
was one of the rules and so that's hard
that's it's hard to find people that can
do that
and also be extraordinarily gifted as an
actor and so we just did a lengthy
audition process and Cynthia walked in I
knew I knew of her yeah from the color
purple but she walked in on the audition
and when she started singing the paint
melted off the walls she was just so
spectacular and you look for those
moments in your career where you sit up
a little straighter and you look to your
casting director you go oh we found
Arlene like you just knew right away
that was her